denn ihr egal in welchem mode ihr seid
egal ob der krieg ich mag oder nicht
wenn ihr mit einem feuerzeug rechtsklick
darauf macht explodiert der einfach
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge der
minecraft facts heute am 29
das weiß ich so genau weil ich das ganze
immer noch am vorproduzieren firma einen
urlaub ich weiß nicht wie oft und wie
viel videos ich das schon gesagt habe
tut noch herzlich leid aber einfach nur
noch mal das geräusch kam diesmal auch
wieder nicht kommen wegen dem
vorproduzieren halt weil ich kann er
keine kommentare lesung keine rauspicken
keinen gewinner
deswegen tut mir das leid und die facts
würden mir per e mail zugesendet per
mail an konkret die mail.com steht auch
in der beschreibung könnt ihr mir oft zu
senden die ihr selbst aus gefunden habt
hoffe ich nämlich weil ich nehme nur
eure factset zusendet ich gucke da keine
anderen videos oder nimm das von ihnen
dem anlass oder aus irgendwelchen keine
ahnung amerikaner machen dass er
mittlerweile auch serien
ich nehme da nicht irgendwie sondern nur
aus euren mails dahin wie die sonne auf
deswegen kann ich dafür nicht
garantieren dass ihr das nicht schon
kennt irgendwoher oder allgemein die
sache ist und ich würde angefangen mit
dem ersten fact und zwar weder
zugesendet von freestyle mit 33 und
statt der ehe und dem an manet und zwar
kam mir in einer letzten folge der fag
mit dem bilderrahmen der funktioniert
aber auch mit einem bogen einer angel so
deswegen habe ich hier einen angel und
allen bogen und speck diamanten von
jeder minecraft erträumt und wir wissen
ich habe mit einem schneeball probiert
wenn man schnee bahrain wird ich kann es
mal ganz kurz nur zeigen ist aber
dekorationen nicht geben einfach mal
schnee ein schneeball und ihr seht
moment und das eigene weg wenn ich
allerdings jetzt hier wieder den
diamanten rein läge so und ich muss mit
einem pfeiler drauf sagt hatte damit weg
es ist einfach weg ist nicht hier dann
würde ich ja noch ein diamanten bekommen
und dann lege ich aber noch in diamant
rein und angel die mit einer angel der
diamant effekt also mit einer angel
einem bogen und mit einem schneeball ich
packte einfach mal schnell rein findet
auf dem schneeberg funktioniert oder ich
kann auch einen bogen reinpacken
wir sehen das auch morgen funktioniert
das items weg wenn man es ab schießt mit
einem bogen
mit der angel handelt oder wenn man es
mit dem schneeball abwirft dann kann
dich freestyle perfekt nummer eins fällt
nummer zwei wurde mir zugesendet von mag
und zwar schreibt er du kannst creeper
zum explodieren bringen wenn du ein
feuerzeug benutzt dafür haben wir hier
einen krieg und ein feuerzeug und ihr
könnt es ganz normal wenn man den
creeper angreift dann explodiert er
irgendwann deinen journal seit im
creative mode explodiert er erst böse
oder kommt erst auf euch zu wenn ihr ihn
angreift und dann explodiert er ich kann
euch mal ganz kurz
jetzt muss ich morgen hier der tut mir
nix im creative mode das wisst ihr
wenn ich im survival mode wer wird denn
direkt auf mich zukommen und dann
explodieren das könnt ihr alle selbst
heraus finde ich will meine welt hier
nicht zwei mal in die luft sprengen
allerdings ihr seht hier ein feuerzeug
ihr seht ich stehe neben dem nichts
passiert der macht nix da steht in der
ecke ganz knuffig der typ welchen
allerdings anzünde hört mal dann
explodiert der direkt wenn ihr egal in
welchem mode ihr seid egal ob der krieg
ich mag oder nicht wenn ihr mit einem
feuerzeug rechtsklick darauf macht
explodiert der einfach der wird dann
wohl irgendwie gezündet dadurch dass sie
mit einem feuerzeug der rechtsweg darauf
macht und ihr seid dabei wäre nicht dass
hierzu klappe weil das ist einfach so
krass ihr könnt quasi wenn euer kumpel
irgendwie okay wenn das könnte ihn
wahrscheinlich nicht viel durch so eine
explosion an haben aber es ist auf jeden
fall cool zu wissen und da kommen 110
mio
und das auf jeden fall fact nummer 2
danke an dich mag ist auf jeden fall
interessant fag nummer drei wurde mir
zugesendet von batuhan oder ungarn
ich nenne ich mal einfach bad waren weil
der mfg barth hat nikon crafter fakt
wenn man mit einer hohen block abbaut
verbraucht die hau sich nicht wenn man
jetzt zum beispiel mal überlegt ich hab
ja eine gold spitzhacke eine stein
schaufel und eine holzhacker also holz
und jetzt bewege ich mich bewege mich in
den games 0
ich habe drei verschiedene blöcke ich
habe hier einmal dieses outfit plankner
mal in augsburg wird englisch lehrer mit
luca ein wohnblock und ein output plank
ich nehme es beispielsweise mal die
stein schaufel und baut damit den hut ab
und ihr seht alle werkzeuge sind
unbenutzt ich bin ab und ihr seht unten
den grünen balken bei der schaufel das
heißt je scheffel ist benutzt
so nehmen wir einen spieltag und bonner
mit beispielsweise diesem wolle block ab
sehen wir die gold spitzhacke ist
benutzt
nehmen wir eine holzhacker und bauen
damit diesen block ab die holzhacker ist
nicht benutzt nehmen die holzhacker und
bauen damit diesen block ab ihr seht die
holzhacker ist nicht benutzt nehme die
holzhacker und bauen damit diesem blog
ab ihr seht die holztag ist nicht
benutzt nehme die holzhacker bauen damit
diese kiste ab ihr seht die holzhacker
es nicht benutzt
egal welchen blockier mit der holzhacker
oder mit einer stein hackl goldpreisen
hacke diamante abwehr macht den diamant
acke abbaut
die holzhacker benutze ich die mit denen
gibt das geht damit zwar genau so
schnell wie mit einer steintafel oder
mit einer holz gold spitzhacke aber sie
benutze ich nicht die benutze ich nur
wenn ihr irgendwas so einfällt hakt und
das auf jeden fall cool zu wissen dann
kann dich bei autoren der letzte fake
ist etwas was mir selbst aufgefallen
dass uns was es kein wirklicher effekt
sondern mehr als wir anfang den ich
eigentlich rausgebracht ob aus der serie
weil sie so was witziges gibt wo man
lachen musste außer den ersten folgen
sondern ist es mehr so was interessantes
ich möchte ich nicht ich was zeigen ist
verbirgt sich in dieser kiste und zwar
dass hier ihr seht einen gold apfel acht
gold blöcke und 6 06 30 in 72 goldbarren
jetzt hängt ihr euch was wir damit
machen
ich möchte euch ganz einfach zeigen wenn
ihr mal überlegt diese goldbarren sind
72 stück 72 durch neun sind acht also 84
von acht gold blöcke plus ein apfel den
ich jetzt nicht eingepackt habe ein
apfel wiegt nicht schon ein kleiner tipp
ergibt einen goldenen apfel dieser gold
also nicht goldenen apfel das ist dieser
notch apple den mann mit acht gold
blöcken gemacht hat und dieser goldene
apfel besteht aus diesen acht gold
blocken welche wieder auf 36 61 72
goldbarren bestehen gold ist das
schwerste metall in diesem ihr diamant
ist nicht so schwer eisen ist auch nicht
so schwer blablabla das heißt der gold
apfel ist das schwerste altem im ganzen
spiel und es sieht so leicht aus dieser
gold apfel wiegt so was von viel dass es
einfach mal so ein kleiner fun fact der
gold apfel ist das schwerste im ganzen
spiel könnt ihr ausrechnen wie viel ein
goldbarren wiegt das x 78 plus das
gewicht von einem apfel der vision award
30 gramm oder so obwohl es schon
schwerer
dafür können schon so 100 gramm wiegen
würde schon sagen keine ahnung kommt aus
den apfel an
aber der gold apfel ist das schwerste
item im spiel bzw der lodge apple mit
diesem gold bleibt bin ich mit den
normalen goldbarren um den apfel rum und
dann will ich auch sagen hier wird immer
heißer an meinem zimmer das ist so heiß
es sind 37 grad ich gehe gleich einer
ich könnte nicht sterben hier drin
das was mit den facts danke an die leute
die mails zugesendet haben ich hoffe ihr
habt das selbst herausgefunden bei sonst
wär s ein bisschen blöd wenn es aus
anderen wie das habt ihr da ist wenn ihr
selber cool effect wird per mail an jobs
an konkreter mail.com dann will ich
sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat und in
die serie feiern und ihr jetzt schon auf
die nächste minecraft folgen freut weil
die kommen jetzt in den nächsten beiden
wochen immer pünktlich am vorproduzieren
dann zeigt mit einer bewertung und ja